ein vakuum in der physik bedeutet nicht
gleich absolute leere im gegenteil
forschungsteams weltweit sind sich laut
der quantenfeldtheorie einig dass solche
anderer raum in wahrheit voller energie
steckt wie großartig wäre es diese
anzuzapfen und als schier
unerschöpfliche energiequelle zu nutzen
würde somit nicht sogar ein perpetuum
mobile möglich dass einen energiegewinn
aus dem nichts meint die unzähligen
theorien dazu sind super spannend und
die interessantesten facts bekommt er
jetzt bei klick zum science fiction hier
gibt es täglich faszinierendes seines
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's und an
dieser stelle nochmal vielen dank für
diesen coolen themenvorschlag von euch
bei whatsapp herzlich willkommen
hört sich erst einmal an wie ein
widerspruch ist aber keiner denn fest
steht das quanten vakuum ist alles
andere als leer
ihr könnt es euch quasi vorstellen wie
einen brodelnden see aus teilchen und
antiteilchen die entstehen und vergehen
quantenmechanische gesetze beschreiben
partikel dena weniger sekundenbruchteile
in die existenz blitzen und dann sofort
wieder verschwinden mit teilchen und
antiteilchen sind beispielsweise
elektronen und positronen gemeint die
zugleich entstehen aber sich auch sofort
gegenseitig wieder zerstrahlen dadurch
entstehen elektromagnetische felder
deren spuren man im universum finden
kann das alles lässt sich wunderbar mit
der heisenbergsche unschärferelation
erklären den nach wandelt sich die
energie die man dem vakuum für kurze
zeit entzieht in die virtuellen teilchen
parum derselbe prozess läuft auch beim
absoluten nullpunkt also bei 273 15 grad
celsius ab daher auch die offizielle
bezeichnung der nullpunkt energie schon
ungewöhnlich schließlich kommen hierbei
alle energetischen prozesse zum
stillstand zumindest bei normaler
materie und nein
das alles sind nicht nur theoretische
konzepte denn schon vor mehr als 70
jahren gelang es dem physiker und
nobelpreisträger will es williams die
quantenfluktuationen in einem vakuum in
einem experiment nachzuweisen vielleicht
habt ihr selbst ja sogar schon mal was
von der sogenannten lamb verschiebung
gehört hier bei verschiedenen sich
bestimmte energieniveaus in der
elektronen hülle von wasserstoff
verursacht wird dieser effekt durch
wechselwirkungen
deshalb lag thrones mit den feldern des
quanten vakuums die vakuum energie
selbst wurde das hat 58 in einem
experiment belegt danach wurde dann der
sogenannte kasimir effekt genannt der
eine kraft beschreibt die auf zwei sehr
eng beieinander liegende parallele
metallplatten wirkt und diese durch das
quanten vakuum zusammendrückt denn
zwischen den platten können sich keine
teilchen befinden deren wellenlänge
größer ist als der abstand der beiden
platten selbst außerhalb der platten
dagegen schon
hier entstehen vielmehr davon als
zwischen den platten und erzeugen so im
großen und ganzen einen druck der die
platten von außen nach innen zusammen
schiebt manche sind ganz vereinnahmen
von der existenz der freien energie wie
sie es nennen die große frage hierbei
wie genau könnten wir das vakuum als
unerschöpfliche energiequelle anzapfen
und nutzen
doch ich muss da gleich enttäuschen denn
diese idee ist nicht umzusetzen denn
fest steht dass warum ist der zustand
der niedrigsten energie so kann ihm also
keine energie entzogen werden so dient
vakuum energie eben nicht als
energiequelle theoretisch gesehen gäbe
es aber einige möglichkeiten
dazu müssten die paarweise auftretenden
teilchen getrennt werden und das ohne
energie aufzuwenden
dann könnten sie weiter einzeln genutzt
werden doch wie soll das in der praxis
funktionieren auf diese frage konnte
bisher noch niemand eine antwort finden
eine weitere einschränkung gibt es
außerdem die energiedichte des vakuums
ist nicht sehr groß so dass sehr sehr
viele teilchen getrennt und eingefangen
werden müssten wenn man sich den kasimir
effekt genauer anschaut könnte man auf
die idee kommen die bewegung der platten
zu nutzen
die ja durch das quanten vakuum
zusammengeschoben werden beispielsweise
könnte man so mit einem hebel gestänge
energie ziehen doch dann ist auch klar
dieselbe energiemenge muss man weder in
das system essen investieren um die
platten wieder zu trennen
doch sowohl esoteriker und esoterikerin
als auch forschungsteams weltweit haben
die hoffnung noch nicht ganz aufgegeben
beispielsweise hat der us physiker
robert forward eine quantenfluktuationen
batterie entwickelt zumindest im
gedankenexperiment ihr werden elektrisch
leitfähige platten gestapelt die alle
mit der gleichen elektrischen ladung
geladen sind so stoßen sie sich ab
entgegengesetzt zur kasimir kraft
die platten zusammenschieben will indem
gedankenexperiment müsste die abstoßung
kraft so eingestellt werden dass sie
etwas schwächer ist als die kraft des
quanten vakuums denn dann würde sich die
energie des elektrischen feldes zwischen
den platten erhöhen und die nullpunkt
energie würde in elektrische energie
umgewandelt
einen ähnlichen gedanken verfolgt auch
ein forschungsteam aus cambridge die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
wollen durch die balance zwischen der
elektrostatischen abstoßung und der
kasimir anziehung kleine sensoren und
schalter basteln und jetzt noch ein
kleiner fun fact für euch am ende 2014
hat ein internationales forschungsteam
eine studie veröffentlicht nach der die
mysteriöse dunkle energie durch das die
anderes quanten vakuum entstehen könnte
wir haben ja hier schon öfter darüber
berichtet fast drei viertel des kosmos
sind schätzungen zufolge mit dieser
exotischen form der energie erfüllt sie
sorgt wohl dafür dass sich das universum
ausdehnt vielleicht hat auch in dieser
sache das nichts eine außer großen licht
große wirkung wenn es neues zu diesem
thema gibt dann erfahrt ihr es natürlich
hier heute gibt es bei uns übrigens den
zehn jahre jubiläum 500.000 abonnenten
spezial stream zu dem thema der letzten
wochen aliens ihr könnt ihnen hier schon
mal vormerken um 18 uhr geht's los und
danach geht es für mitglieder und patty
uns noch weiter stellt uns gerne jetzt
schon eure fragen zu diesem thema die
wir dann im stream beantworten können
gerne auf whatsapp der link ist hier und
ich freue mich auf viele fragen und
natürlich auch auf euch im livestream
bis dann alles gleich bleibt dran